BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the fourth segment
in our week-long exploration
of Creative Sandbox Gallery
uses of our technology.
We have a really, really fun
couple of things we're going
to look at today.
Today we're going
to be looking at
some Google+ API usage.
It's pretty kinetic.
There's a lot of action
involved.
So I think it should be a pretty
exciting and pretty fun
conversation.
Before we begin, I want to
introduce a colleague of mine
out on the West Coast.
Please note his powerful
mustache.
Jonathan, can you say hello?
JONATHAN BERI: How's it going?
My name is Jon Beri.
I'm the developer advocate
for Google+.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
Jonathan is going to be here to
answer questions that the
agencies have, answer questions
that viewers have.
As you guys are watching this,
and if things come up that you
like answered, either by the
folks at the agencies who
built these very fun
applications, or by Jonathan
on the developers' team here at
Google, please go ahead and
put those into our
moderator tool.
And we'll put that link
up over in the
course of this Hangout.
Please do not hesitate
to ask questions.
We will answer everything
we get.
With that said, let's go ahead
and we're going to talk with
Resn first, followed
by Goodby and Hook.
Let's take a look at Resn's
video, so you have a sense of
what they did with
the Google+ API.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Resn presents Face Arcade,
a Google Hangouts game.
Do you want to game with your
friends online but get tired
of all the cables?
Using powerful Google and Resn
technologies, you can now
control games using your
face and a Web cam.
-How many games, Face Arcade?
-How many, you ask?
Face Arcade gives you not none,
not two, not even four,
but four life-like games.
-Requires no actual CDs.
-They don't exist.
-Have you ever wondered
what it would be
like to be a snake?
Wonder no more.
Control a caterpillar with
your face in Browzilla.
It's the next best thing.
-What about ancient history?
-Old news.
-The Greeks were notorious
for fun.
Were you?
With Face Arcade's TechnoYawn,
you can now play a tastefully
re-imagined Rome of the ages.
This unlimited time offer from
Face Arcade also includes
Noddy Nelly.
Nice Noddy.
-What about feline manipulation
through the power
of self-hypnosis?
-Impossible!
-Now you can harness your inner
mentalism in the comfort
of your own fireplace.
Best of all, Google Hangouts
lets you play against your
friends all across the
world and battle them
face-to-face-to-face-to-face.
Face Arcade Off.
No more playing solo.
Best of all, Face
Arcade is free.
-But how?
-It won't take one,
not even two, but
just three easy steps.
First, go to your
Google account.
Start a Hangout.
Don't forget to add
your friends.
Then, add the app.
It's that simple.
You'll be battling your
friends in no time.
Play Face Arcade.
Made in Resn.
-Resn presents Face Arcade,
a Google Hangouts game.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
Face Arcade--
the first question I have for
you guys at Resn before you
introduce yourselves is, are you
certain that no one will
get a concussion
with your game?
Once we answer that, you guys
over at Resn, can you give us
a quick intro and a walk through
of who's on the line
today, and what your roles
are at the agency?
MARK WORDSWORTH: Sure.
Sure Firstly, we accept no
responsibility for any damage
caused by playing the game.
I'm Mark, the producer
at Resn.
WADE COWIN: I'm Wade, a
[INAUDIBLE] at Resn.
EMLYN: My name's Emlyn.
I'm a senior developer
at Resn.
BRANDEL ZACHERNUK:
Hi, I'm Brandel.
I'm an experience developer
at Resn.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
And for those of you watching,
it is 8:30 in the morning for
them out in New Zealand, so if
it looks a little dark, and
they look a little tired, they
are being real troopers in the
office that early.
Guys, I'm going to ask you guys
a couple questions and
just would love to hear your
takes on what it took to
develop what you did.
Where the ideas came from,
who was involved.
Let's just start with what was
the idea generation process,
because this is obviously a very
fun, very funny, but also
very unexpected use
of the technology.
How did you guys come
up with the idea?
Who generated that idea and who
got together to say, this
is what we should do?
WADE COWIN: The idea just came
from looking at all the
different things we could get
from the API and realizing
that we could get some really
interesting, random
stuff out of it.
The goal was just to make
something really
ridiculous and fun.
And so we started looking at all
the APIs and just going,
what can we do with this that's
going to make all the
users look completely absurd
and ridiculous.
That was probably one of initial
key points that we hit
upon which was the creative
hook for the whole idea--
making people look ridiculous.
BRIAN MOROZ: Excellent.
WADE COWIN: So with the social
engagement bringing everyone
down to a level of looking
really ridiculous, we were
hoping that the game was going
to work as kind of a social
lubricant in Hangouts.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
So making people look ridiculous
together, that was
the creative idea.
Excellent.
I love it.
And it does do that.
And it is super fun.
How did you guys interact
with the technology?
When I say that, you said
there's lots of things that
you realized the API could do.
How did you A, figure out what
was possible and B, then say
OK, out of all of these
possibilities, these are the
five or six elements we
want to work with.
And we'll build a game around
a handful of these.
How did you guys go
through that?
MARK WORDSWORTH: At first we
didn't realize how the
[INAUDIBLE] would be
presented, like how
noisy it would be.
We knew that we wanted to work
with particular tracking
elements, so the ideas
were born from
these individual elements.
And then the ideas were refined
once we knew how high
fidelity the data was
coming out of it.
Probably Brendal and Emlyn it'll
be better to talk about
that process of the testing
of the data there.
EMLYN HUGHES: Yeah, there's
pretty good
documentation around it.
Looking through that gave us a
good idea about the points on
the face that are getting
tracked and
that sort of thing.
Yes, breaking it down into
facial elements and saying,
OK, well, yeah, what's
going to look silly.
OK, moving forward and back
really quickly with your head,
that's going to look
pretty silly.
What sort of creative can
we stick that with.
BRIAN MOROZ: So when you were
doing that, you found the
points of the face that could
be read and then the motions
that you could detect
with that.
How did you guys test that?
Did you just have a lot of
people in-house, like going
like this a lot, or how did
you figure out that it was
actually going to work?
EMLYN HUGHES: Yeah,
pretty much.
We had a lot of squeaking
seats.
You'd be sitting around
coding and you'd hear
[SQUEAKING SOUNDS].
You'd turn around and someone
would be rocking around on
their seats.
Yeah, fortunately we had a
couple of interns at the time
and they got pretty
good workouts.
[INAUDIBLE]
strong muscles.
BRIAN MOROZ: Excellent.
A lot of in-house user testing
going on to make sure that it
was accurate and it worked.
Let me ask you this-- who all
was involved building this?
Because it's not like the idea
came to you guys and, correct
me if I'm wrong, it sounds like
it came pretty quickly.
You figured out, OK, we can
make people look silly.
And then we can map that to
something that will be fun and
competitive, but social.
Who did you pull in and say,
this is the team that's going
to come up with what the game
is going to look like, what
the games are, how it's going
to be technically feasible?
How did you determine who was
going to be involved?
MARK WORDSWORTH: It was open
season for the whole team
across Resn in Wellington
and Amsterdam.
We're about 20 strong,
all-in-all.
But I guess the full development
team and the full
production team ended up being
around ten people.
But it was all open season.
Everyone throughout Resn
could contribute ideas.
The creative process went from
the very start to the very end
of the production cycle.
People could throw
a gag in here and
there all the way through.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
And who made a decision, or was
it just that group of ten?
Is that who made the decisions
as to OK, here's the 50 ideas
that we're going to make
it into the five.
Is that how that worked?
MARK WORDSWORTH: Pretty much.
We kind of, this is what
[INAUDIBLE] about the bitch
process around the time we were
invited to collaborate in
the Hangout Hackathon.
We had a lot of ideas
at that point and we
boiled them all down.
WADE COWIN: We tried to make it
a ridiculous matrix of all
the key points that we wanted
to fulfill with the ideas,
ranging from feasibility right
up to awesomeness.
So we had to tic all the boxes
in each concept just run
through this thorough
check list.
Make sure it was good enough
and it went from there.
I guess one of the key things
about having a game with a lot
of little micro-games in it,
was it was good for getting
everyone on the team a little
piece of the project
that they could own.
There's a lot of people just
working on little separate
elements, bringing
those together.
And I think that adds to the
creative of it as well.
There's a lot of ideas and
a lot of wackiness
and a lot of insanity.
Just because it comes from
all across the board.
EMLYN HUGHES: Yeah, that was
one of the things that,
because it was so, so modular
that we could divided up into
nice sort of discrete chunks,
and hand it off to the smaller
sets of one designer, one
developer kind of thing.
It was a nice way to
do it, I think.
BRIAN MOROZ: Interesting,
so it was actually very
decentralized setup when it
comes to the individual pieces
rather than having a particular
creative or a
particular developer say I am
the one who's going to approve
everything and design this and
I'll have people work on it.
It sounds like it was very much
a ground up, lots and
lots of people making all these
individual pieces that
you guys stitched together,
which is a really interesting
way to go about it.
On the note of how you actually
got it made, it
sounds like all these discrete
teams had their
pieces and made them.
And then you pulled
them together.
Did you guys have help
from our side,
from the Google side?
Or is this something that you
guys did totally on your own?
You had the API.
You understood it,
put it together.
How did that work?
EMLYN HUGHES: Yeah, that was
pretty much just looking
through the API documentation
to get a good
idea of what was there.
And then we did some prototyping
and some testing
just to see what sort of data
came out of it and how we
might use it.
BRANDEL ZACHERNUK: Then the
framework that we put together
for everybody to work within.
EMLYN HUGHES: We had sort of a
framework that managed all the
multiplayer aspects and
server side stuff.
And then we had each of the
individual games sort of just
worked by themselves.
And then we had teams working
on each of the games.
And then we had sort of an
overall architecture to pull
them all together and make it
sort of one linear process.
BRIAN MOROZ: So that they could
just basically plug
their piece of the
game into the--
EMLYN HUGHES: Yeah, exactly.
BRIAN MOROZ: Got it.
Got it.
On the technical side,
what was the one--
if there was one--
was there one particular
hurdle that was quite
difficult technically speaking,
or anything that you
guys really had trouble
getting through?
EMLYN HUGHES: Yeah, we sort of
underestimated the difficulty
in setting up some sort of
peer-based multiplayer system.
We had a basic system to begin
with, and it kind of quickly
became apparent that it wasn't
going to hold up.
So we went back to the drawing
board basically and spent a
lot more time planning out
how all the multiplayer
interaction was going to work.
Because you're not dealing with
a centralized server and
this stuff is all sort
of peer-to-peer.
There's a bit more complication
involved in
coordinating a lot of the
multiplayer aspects.
BRIAN MOROZ: That makes sense.
When did that occur?
When did that issue come up?
Early on, or was it like
the week before?
EMLYN HUGHES: Reasonably
late in the game.
Probably about a week out.
We sort of realized that we were
going to have to sit down
and do some more in-depth
planning.
But what we came up with
was really good.
It ended up being reasonably
robust.
And it was an interesting
architectural experience to
have to go through.
BRIAN MOROZ: It always comes
up about a week before,
doesn't it?
EMLYN HUGHES: Yeah.
A few late nights.
BRIAN MOROZ: How long was the
development process all totaled?
I mean obviously, the give or
take, what was the general
timeline like for you guys?
EMLYN HUGHES: I think we were
originally planning to try,
and we spent a week of kind
of initial planning and
pre-production.
And then we were trying to hit a
game a day for the Hackathon
in the second week.
And we almost got there.
I think we planned on
doing five games.
We ended up getting to four.
And then after the two
weeks, we had a
reasonably solid product.
But there was a few things that
weren't quite happy with,
so I think we spent probably
about a week or so just sort
of polishing things up, and
cleaning them up, getting them
to a better standard.
So, yeah, about three
or four weeks.
BRIAN MOROZ: Three
or four weeks?
Wow, OK.
So that was actually
really quick.
That's really amazing,
actually.
I didn't realize that you guys
put this together so rapidly.
How did you get the word out,
or how did you get people
involved in the game?
Is it something where it
was completely viral?
You told your friends, said
tell your friends.
What did you guys do to get
people to know that
the game was there?
WADE COWIN: We made a ridiculous
video, pretty much.
That was our whole campaign, was
making a ridiculous video.
I guess trying to show people
how much fun they can have
with something free
and just sent that
around wherever we could.
And it seemed to get picked up
quite well and hopefully got
people playing it as well.
MARK WORDSWORTH: We also tried
communicating out every
[INAUDIBLE] development.
Every single day we blogged on
our Google+ page and our
Facebook page.
We tried to communicate all the
way through the process.
WADE COWIN: Resn Labs has got
a lot of-- there's a blog
almost every second day at at
least on Resn Labs going
through the process, kind of
feeling our pain as we rushed
towards the deadline.
That's full of a lot of the
development process there.
We can look back on it.
Yeah.
BRIAN MOROZ: But you were
actually broadcasting the fact
that it was going to be coming
during the actual development
process, is that true?
Is that what you
just mentioned?
MARK WORDSWORTH: Yeah.
BRIAN MOROZ: Interesting.
So you didn't wait until it was
a polished product, ready
to launch, and give
it a big launch.
You guys were letting people in
as it was happening, as it
was being built.
BRANDEL ZACHERNUK: Yeah.
We were conscious of the need
to make something that would
be able to stand up
aesthetically throughout that
development process.
So we made sure that the
visual style and the
interactions were such that we
could show them at any point
and they would be still
pretty hilarious--
confusing and shocking, but
also quite appealing.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
I guess just one last question
for you guys
on the broader front.
Given that you guys did four
games in a handful of weeks,
you got kind of slammed at the
last minute on how multiple
servers were going to work
with the architecture.
You were giving out little bits
and pieces and images and
ideas as you were developing
it, to the public.
If someone wanted to do
something similar, if someone
said, I want to do something
like that.
I want to do it within a month,
develop something
really fun with the Hangouts
API, and I want to follow
their path.
What would be the one big
piece of advice that
you would give them?
EMLYN HUGHES: I guess from a
technical point of view,
probably the debugging we found
reasonably difficult, in
that there's a lot of
noise, a lot of
communications going on--
there's a lot of
things talking.
So your debug consoles and
things fill up pretty quickly.
We ended up outputting a lot
of our debug stuff to a
front-end to the UI so you
could read the debug
information on the Web page,
rather than through your
consoles and stuff like that.
I think debugging is a pretty
important part of the
developmental process.
So yeah, that was one thing
that we had to try and
establish fairly early on to
make sure that it was a
smoother ride.
EMLYN: Yeah.
BRIAN MOROZ: So debugging.
Put it up front.
Anything else?
Anything from the creative side
that you would recommend?
WADE COWIN: I think it's
important to make sure that
how you are taking all that
data, you've still, at the end
of the day.
you've got to turn it into
something entertaining.
And there's a there's a lot of
freedom with what you can do
with face tracking.
It's pretty massive, really.
So I think if you're looking for
a creative idea, you don't
have to far on something like
that to really start getting
into some really insane
territory.
EMLYN HUGHES: It was also easy
to get up and going as well.
Anyone looking to do any
development in it, we've got
things working on screen
really quickly.
Within a matter of hours, we had
things tracking to faces
and moving around.
BRANDEL ZACHERNUK: [INAUDIBLE]
and even making single games
was really, really simple.
The only complexity was when
we had follow the leader.
If it was two player, then
it'd be simpler as well.
There are a lot of things
that can come
straight out of the box.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
Folks over at Goodby, why don't
we start with you guys.
You each want to give a quick
round of introduction of who
is on the call today.
JESSICA HARDY: Yeah, sure.
DEAN RUBINSTEIN: Hey there.
I'm Dean Rubinstein.
I'm the account leader
across all things
Google here at Goodby.
JESSICA HARDY: And I'm account
manager, Jessica Hardy, for
Google+ here at Goodby.
LISA KOURAKOS: And I am Lisa,
the assistant account manager
for Google at Goodby.
BRIAN MOROZ: OK.
And now folks over at Hook.
MICHAEL WATTS: Hello.
My name's Michael Watts.
I'm a producer at Hook.
AARON SCHWARTZ: Hi, I'm
Aaron Schwartz.
I'm the creative lead
here at Hook.
BRIAN MOROZ: See, you
guys get headbands.
MICHAEL WATTS: Oh, yeah.
We made those things.
CHRIS: I'm Chris.
I'm a technical director
at Hook.
BRAD: I'm Brad.
I did the game development
here.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
Very cool.
Thank you guys.
I think this looks like a very,
very fun game to play
when it launches publicly.
Why don't you guys give us just
an overview of where the
idea came from, how you worked
together to develop it, and
just what the back-end
idea was.
Why did you guys come
up with this
particular use of the API?
JESSICA HARDY: Sure.
Well, I get started with some
of the really cool features,
like the facial tracking
effects, that we really wanted
to highlight and do something
cool with-- something that's
never been done before.
And just knowing that social
gaming is very popular, we
wanted to take advantage of that
competitive spin and put
together a really
cool game that
would show those features.
DEAN RUBINSTEIN: We also wanted
to do something that
was fun for us and something
that also hadn't kind of been
overdone in this this sphere.
And Ping-Pong was something that
a lot of folks here do
here to blow off steam or
[INAUDIBLE] and thought
everybody else might
want the same.
So.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
And so between Goodby and Hook,
how did you guys work
together on this?
What was the connection point
and the responsibilities?
How did that break out?
JESSICA HARDY: It's very
collaborative.
I know we've spent a lot of
quality time with Hook, going
back and forth developing
this game.
There was a lot of code that
went into putting it together.
Ultimately, it ended up us
being the go-between with
Google and Hook.
Once they would develop
it, we would vet it.
And then when there was
feedback, we'd go back to Hook
and just look for where we could
make enhancements and
make it as smooth as
possible game.
LISA KOURAKOS: We knew that
Hook was super attuned to
detail as we are over
at the Goodby team.
And they're really great paying
attention to those
kinds of things.
They were excellent through
that whole process.
MICHAEL WATTS: Plus once
they hire us, they
can't get rid of us.
DEAN RUBINSTEIN: We don't
want to say it, but--
BRIAN MOROZ: What was the
idea generation process
like over at Goodby?
How did you guys come
up with this?
Who was involved?
Was this one person's spark of
genius, was it a group of
people working together?
How did this come about?
JESSICA HARDY: Well, I think
it was really an
all-hands-on-deck sort
of situation.
We had production, concepting,
creative concepting.
I mean, account people
were involved.
Everybody pretty much
had hands in it.
I just think with the amount of
times that we've played and
seen the process, you discover
things as the development
process goes, that enhance
the creative.
It's been a work in progress.
LISA KOURAKOS: And I also
know that we really--
Hangout has these incredible
features, such as Hangout
effects and facial tracking.
And we really wanted to leverage
those features.
A lot of our game development
was based on figuring out how
we could enhance them, and
make them really fun, and
incorporate them
into the game.
And that drove a lot of
our creative process.
BRIAN MOROZ: Interesting.
So the technology drove some of
the ideation in this case.
It wasn't, we have this idea,
let's figure out what
technology works.
It was, this technology has
lots of opportunities.
What can we do that's
interesting with that.
LISA KOURAKOS: Absolutely.
It definitely went both ways.
DEAN RUBINSTEIN: I think it's a
lot of the real time type of
stuff when you're dealing with
working on a new platform and
seeing what works, and actually
getting really
excited and self correcting
as you go along.
Which is also something
that we are
excited to take on here.
BRIAN MOROZ: Who worked
on the project?
Obviously you guys have
introduced yourself.
I assume the team was
a little larger.
So both on the Goodby side and
on the Hook side, what were
the roles had to come together
to really make this happen?
Was it a massive group
of people?
Was it a very small group?
What was that like?
JESSICA HARDY: Well I think our
interactive producer was
obviously very heavily involved
in making sure that
all the game updates
were flowing.
And then also we had operations
involved just
because we are coordinating
with several
people on our end.
I know we have a few creative
minds in here who have put
some input into the copy and
the look and feel of it.
But ultimately, that was
established early on by some
of our top teams.
DEAN RUBINSTEIN: There was a
little bit of everybody.
And then, of course the core
team coming together.
And the good thing for us about
having a wide net is
that we had a lot
of fresh eyes.
So over the course of the
project we have a lot of
people using and seeing it,
seeing how they can enhance
it, quite a few kitchen tables,
add milestones to see
how we could make the project
better and better.
BRIAN MOROZ: And on the
technical side, folks over at
Hook, but also at Goodby as
well, is there anything that
happened during the development
process that was a
particularly difficult hurdle
that you guys had to get over?
Or was it all smooth sailing
all the way through?
MICHAEL WATTS: I mean
rare that a project
is all smooth sailing.
I think anybody will
admit that.
Thankfully, we'd done quite a
bit of Hangout's API work
before we jumped into
this with Goodby.
And we were on a very
condensed timeline.
We essentially had about two
weeks to get our first
prototype out and then around
eight weeks to fulfill the
first round of the project.
We like to approach those
types of things as an
iterative process.
So we, soon after prototyping,
got the first version out in
two weeks or less and got
people playing it.
And then started rolling in
different API features into
the game and making it a more
rich user experience.
As opposed to trying to
implement 20 features up
front, show the game halfway
through, and then fix what we
can before it went out.
So it was a very evolutionary
type of development process.
We started off with playing with
your mouse, and that was
kind of lame.
And we tried other methods and
ultimately netted out with
face tracking.
And once that happened,
a lot of the
game parameters changed.
And it's definitely a living
process as went through those
eight weeks.
BRIAN MOROZ: But nothing in
particular that was a
particular technical
[INAUDIBLE].
It was iterative, just kind of
bit-by-bit moving through.
MICHAEL WATTS: Yeah, exactly.
From my previous comment about
having done a little bit of
Hangout development before this,
we knew to stay away
from some certain things and
to approach things from a
different angle.
As the Resn guys said, the
peer-to-peer system wasn't
quite robust enough for them, so
we took the route of using
a centralized server from the
beginning, just to make sure
that we could get things up
and running quickly, have
something that could traverse
the globe in these toolkits.
And then ultimately scale
out to a public version.
DEAN RUBINSTEIN: And on our
end, it's like, if things
aren't bumpy, it's
not advertising.
It's certainly not innovative
advertising.
If they're not bumpy, it's
when I get concerned.
MICHAEL WATTS: Brad broke his
skateboard a couple of times,
but I'm not sure that counts.
DEAN RUBINSTEIN: Yeah.
MICHAEL WATTS: Good thing.
BRIAN MOROZ: Very cool.
I think I have a very
important question
for you guys now.
Just who is the best
at Ping-Pong?
MICHAEL WATTS: Oh well,
Brad made it, so--
BRIAN MOROZ: There's some
cheats put in there.
MICHAEL WATTS: Oh, yeah.
It knows his face
it [INAUDIBLE]
BRIAN MOROZ: It tracks
his face.
DEAN RUBINSTEIN: I always feel
that there's an unfair
advantage to those who
built it, but I won't
get into this theory.
JESSICA HARDY: I've had
a lot of practice.
BRIAN MOROZ: So how are you
guys-- so Goodby, how are you
guys going to have the folks
at large engage with this?
What's the plan to roll out?
What is the goal?
What would be your ideal end
point for this, as far as who
gets involved and
how they use it?
JESSICA HARDY: The first
iteration of the game actually
launched during Ad Week and
right now it's available in
several different toolkits
that have been traveling
around the globe at
specific events.
And then ultimately, we're
going to push out another
phase that's specific
to agencies.
So the idea will be to really
kind of tap into that
motivation and that competitive
nature to get
creatives involved and really
want to dominate, and score
the most points, and show their
bragging rights off.
That'll be the next roll out.
And that video is a little
bit of a teaser of
that version to come.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
Agency versus agency.
Prepare yourselves folks.
Those of you who are involved
who are at an agency, start
stretching out a little bit.
JESSICA HARDY: Absolutely.
You might as well start
limbering up now.
BRIAN MOROZ: So one final
question for you guys--
the same question that I asked
the folks over at Resn.
If you had one piece of advice
to give people who are trying
to develop a Hangout API that's
something that's going
to be really fun and engaging,
that sounds just like-- the
Resn guys did this in a very
short period of time.
What's your one piece of advice
on the creative side,
and one piece of advice
in the technical side?
LISA KOURAKOS: I think,
from a creative
standpoint, it takes time.
But as we said, the platform
allowed a lot of room for
exploration and creativity.
And I think that was a really
exciting part of the process.
As we really dug into it, our
creators had a lot of range.
So while it took time, it's
definitely a doable platform
and an exciting platform
to work on.
DEAN RUBINSTEIN: I think to that
point too, I would just
add from the creator
standpoint-- as account people
love to do--
that I think that either you
shoot for the stars and see
how close you can get to it.
It's like anything else
you can try and do.
Don't limit yourself and
just try and make
some really cool stuff.
BRIAN MOROZ: And Hook, anything
from the technical
side that you would say is the
one thing to keep in mind when
doing the stuff?
CHRIS: I would say one thing
that's important is to make
sure that you have sort of a
well-thought out testing
regime, so that when you get
to the beta of the product.
Especially if you're trying to
work on a multiplayer game,
you need to develop
enough test cases.
With this platform, you need
to coordinate your testing
with multiple people to make
sure that it plays across all
the possible scenarios that
can come through in a
Hangout-- so making
sure of that.
You know, people can enter and
exit a Hangout at many points.
So making sure that if you are
building a game or something,
that no matter when a person
comes in or comes out, or what
happens, or how many people are
in the Hangout, that the
game adapts so that everybody
is sort of seeing the
application in a way that makes
sense when it's made
available to them.
And there are many more
scenarios that can happen when
you're building something in
this sort of system than if
you are just building a game
that two people are playing on
the same computer, or
something like that.
BRIAN MOROZ: Right.
Right.
All right.
That's a great point that with
Hangouts, it is something
where people are-- yeah, I
hadn't even thought of that--
where people are popping
in and out.
How do you handle
that situation?
Jonathan, hanging out over on
the West Coast, what are your
thoughts on both of these, or
questions for these guys?
JONATHAN BERI: I guess I'll
touch on the last point.
Hangouts are very dynamic.
You're never know when a user's
going to join, when
they're going to leave.
Somebody rejoins, like we lost
GSP for a few minutes, and
they just popped back in.
And nobody was the wiser.
Thank you for the example,
because [INAUDIBLE]
When we designed the API, we
added those features into the
actual platforms.
As a program, you can know when
somebody joins or when
somebody leaves, where do they
join, and have your app
respond to that.
And say, maybe throw up a
loading screen saying, there
are four people playing
this game right now,
you're next in the queue.
Or change the table, if
it's appropriate.
You can add another person
to the table
and things like that.
Just as Hangouts are dynamic
and responsive, we made the
API in such a way to allow
for that functionality.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
And just to do a quick wrap
before we get to the questions
that people have sent in.
We'll start with the Resn.
Folks at Resn, now that you have
Jonathan captured here on
camera, what would be the one
or two things that you would
love to see from the Google+
APIs that he guarantees he's
going to do, or at
least will try?
It's early in the morning, so
if you don't have anything,
Jonathan's fine with that.
JONATHAN BERI: That's easy.
EMLYN HUGHES: It was
all pretty good.
I guess one thing, like I
mentioned before, some of the
debugging stuff was quite noisy,
and as part of the
polling to get all the network
data going back and forth, it
seemed to slow down the Chrome
debugger quite a bit.
Do you have any plans to maybe
change the way that that
system might work to make
it a little bit
more efficient, perhaps?
JONATHAN BERI: So starting with
debugging, both groups
said that that was a
challenge for them.
And we know that.
Actually, what's a funny thing
that ends up happening,
everybody works on this big
scale project, they all figure
out that debugging's hard, and
they write their own debugging
infrastructure, or system,
or toolkit, right?
I actually have seen a
bunch of people do
the exact same problem.
First thing that we start out
is, part of our weekly office
hours, we've been educating
people on best practices for
debugging and some of the tips
and tricks that we were seeing
in the wild.
Definitely cleaning up the tools
is high on our priority.
And making the debugger better
and tuning the API to make it
better is things that are
definitely on target for fix.
In general, I think you guys
all do the same route.
Using the client, using the
Chrome Developer Tools is a
powerful system and actually
gets you pretty far along.
So combining us fixing it and
just taking better advantage
of the tools there, I think
solves most people's problems.
EMLYN HUGHES: Yeah.
I mean, it wasn't too
much of a problem.
Once we realized that having the
consoles and things open,
it would slow down after while,
we built some little
things on screen that would
output the ticks
and stuff like that.
And that worked pretty
well from then on.
JONATHAN BERI: We can
always do better.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
And now, Goodby and Hook, any
thoughts for Jonathan, if he
could grant you a wish for
your next project?
MICHAEL WATTS: Chris and Wade
might have some others, but I
want some of Jon's
famous gelato.
It's posted all over the place
but, nobody gets any.
JONATHAN BERI: I'm going to
make that my number one.
CHRIS: One thing that would be
helpful would be maybe a
little bit more complete access
to the person's, the
participant's, person object
from the Google API.
Because there's a lot of--
it would be nice
if you could--
right now you get sort of the
person's profile image, their
name, and a few other things.
But it would be nice if there
were some way to pull in more
of their person object to
possibly get like their
location or any of the other.
There's a large data set that
comes with a person being a
Google+ person that would be
nice to possibly have access
to some more of that in Hangouts
without needing to
rely on the Google+ REST API.
MICHAEL WATTS: I also think
it be nice to--
people I think get a little
big confused when they log
into an app from something,
invited to an app from
somebody, and they have
to click on the left
bar to load it up.
Maybe a streamlined way of
auto-loading the app like
people were able to do with
our initiation URLs.
Or if we put the GID
into the URL.
But if that was kind of
automated for the API, I think
that would help a lot of people
in terms [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS: Yeah.
An easier way to direct launch
the apps would be better.
It's a little difficult
right now.
JONATHAN BERI: So starting
with the
first question, gelato.
I make gelato at home, for
anybody who doesn't know that.
And I did a Hangout on
air teaching people.
Yeah.
It makes about a pint a trip.
I don't think it will make it
all the way to you guys, but
if you visit San Francisco--
MICHAEL WATTS: It's frozen
all the way to Michigan.
Just put it outside.
It'll get here.
JONATHAN BERI: But leaving
California, I don't know.
Anyway, the [INAUDIBLE],
that's a
great piece of feedback.
We're always trying
to improve that.
We're also trying to improve
the REST API to
provide more data.
I think you should expect
more things down
there in the future.
But was there pieces of database
besides the location
that you would love to use, or
just, it would be great if it
was better?
CHRIS: I think that
there's a lot of
different options in there.
I don't have anything
specific.
But I know there were a couple
things we had talked about
during the project that if we
had been able to pull data in
from that person object.
Part of it depends
upon how much the
person has filled out.
I could envision apps where
posts that people had put up
or something like that
could be important.
Or if you're trying
to make an app.
Any sort of app that would
involve connecting people with
other people in their circles
would probably need to start
with the person object, or at
least some way to get access
to their connections.
You can grab some of that right
now with the REST API.
It's just that, it's sort
of in two places.
I guess, I don't know, may have
seen it as sort, if the
two were merged a
little bit more.
Because they're sort of--
to me, they sort of serve--
they're sort of two parts
of a similar ecosystem.
JONATHAN BERI: Got it.
Noted.
BRIAN MOROZ: So we will wrap up
by taking a couple of the
questions that have come
in via the moderator.
The first question--
very important--
out of LA.
How long did it take to
make the headbands?
The question that has come in,
I think they were pre-made.
I cannot tell you how long it
took me to get the wristband.
I was just given it.
I think the headbands are a
fantastic touch and you guys
you keep those at all times.
MICHAEL WATTS: [INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN MOROZ: They
never come off.
MICHAEL WATTS: Never.
BRIAN MOROZ: The second question
is, what technology
is used on the back end to make
people ridiculous together?
I think that we answered that.
Essentially it's the Google+
API, specifically with regards
to Hangouts, right?
It's very easy to make people
ridiculous together with that
particular piece
of technology.
A question that came in that I
thought was actually pretty
key was, besides
Hangout games--
I'm reading this here-- what
other types of innovations are
possible using the
Google+ API?
And that's from Daniel
out of planning.
What else are you guys
looking at besides?
These are both kind of gaming
elements in Hangouts.
Are you looking at other
ways to use that API?
Are there other things that you
guys have thought about
before, but decided not to do?
Or have you been mostly focused
on the Hangouts kind
of gaming element?
LISA KOURAKOS: I think the one
thing that we're really
excited about, especially with
our agency tournament
eventually launching is, we want
to get the creative eyes
to see where this platform
can go and what
people can do with it.
And we thought having the agency
tournament would be a
really fun way to kick that
off and give us the
opportunity to start
that conversation.
JONATHAN BERI: And I'd say from
working with a lot of
partners who've been buidling
apps and the developer in the
garage, we see about three major
types of apps that are
being built.
The game is a great use case,
especially because it's fun
and engaging.
But a big, big chunk of them
are around broadcast.
So Hangouts on Air, like we're
doing right now, are broadcast
video that streams over
YouTube and Google+.
It's kind of hard to manage--
switching between who's on
camera, the mike volume, all
those kind of things.
We are building tools
around broadcast.
And the other one is taking
traditional productivity-style
web apps and bringing it
into a collaborative
platform like Hangouts.
One [INAUDIBLE] out of Denmark,
I believe, they have
the traditional scrum boards
with post-it notes
all over the place.
We can drag and drop
across the board.
And they are doing that
in real time.
And they have a web app
that's kind of cool.
And they get a lot
of use out of it.
But when they brought
it to Hangout.
Now it's totally immersive.
It's like, the distributed
teams are right there and
they're all doing project
planning and work on the same
board together.
It's games, productivity,
and broadcast.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
Any last comments in general,
or questions for Jonathan,
folks on the call, Resn,
Goodby, and Hook?
LISA KOURAKOS: I think
we're good.
BRIAN MOROZ: Everyone is good.
All right.
Thank you guys so much for
jumping on in various time
zones and various parts of the
world to discuss how you guys
built these incredibly fun
applications which, by the
way, for those who are watching,
can be found at
creativesandbox.com.
dot com.
Tomorrow we are talking about
the GO API, for those of you
who are interested in
that, tune in then.
Otherwise, thank you guys
so much for joining.
And hopefully one of you will
develop a 3-D application for
the API so this works next
time we try that.
All right.
Thanks guys.
Have a wonderful afternoon.
Bye.